cette rue paisible de jour est animé la
nuit dans cet arrondissement
multiculturelle et chaud de la capitale
elle est maintenant synonyme de
contagion et dans cette corée du sud qui
compte plus de 600 postes de dépistage
un message est lancé aux personnes qui
ont pu côtoyer un homme infecté à la
coved 19 dans les bars et les boîtes de
nuit du quartier
faites vous testez les autorités
sanitaires ses vertus elle est retracée
elle consulte notamment les données de
téléphonie en vertu d'une loi
d'exception
elle remonte le fil de la propagation en
obtenant les renseignements sur toute
personne contaminée comme son nom et ses
déplacements donc le patient est invité
à enrichir les enregistrements
électroniques par les éléments de
souvenirs qui peut lui revenir à
l'esprit donc typiquement ah oui je suis
allé à tel endroit donc à oui j'avais
discuté avec telle personne ces
chercheurs français est l'auteur d'un
rapport sur le modèle sud coréen de
lutte contre la copie 19 lancers
retraçage de prospective une ouverture
une éruption instantanée dans la vie
privée et ensuite on referme mais la
peur de voir sa vie bouleversée et son
identité sexuelle dévoilé dans cette
corée du sud encore conservatrice a été
trop forte
bon nombre de clients ont laissé de
fausses coordonnées à l'entrée des clubs
et reste introuvable
je pense que ça veut d'abord dire que le
système en question qui depuis le mois
de février vivait d'une certaine façon
sa première mise en oeuvre est en train
de montrer un peu les limites de
l'exercice
indigné ciblés par des commentaires
homophobes la communauté lgbt qu a exigé
que le dépistage soit anonyme
la loi strictement encadré a déjà été
révisé pour corriger des ratés la
divulgation des données personnelles des
personnes contaminées est désormais
limité à l'âge et au genre c'est déjà
trop pour cette spécialiste des droits
de la personne et au chili
elle espère que la base de données
hébergées à l'extérieur du gouvernement
sera détruite comme prévu à la fin de
l'épidémie
il s'est libéré au bras du canada séoul